um alright guys well thanks for hosting
me to a podcast at the Jocko podcast
studio for those of our listeners that
don't know about you guys I think we
should start with some quick intros and
then start talking about the new program
you're working on so Xhaka why don't you
start off cool I was in the military for
twenty years and then I retired and when
I retired I started working with
civilians primarily and teaching them
about leadership that I had learned was
in the military
mm-hmm and that culminated in a book you
know another that ended up kind of
morphing into a book called extreme
ownership and that book came out and
that book done pretty well and that kind
of morphed into a podcasts so I have a
podcast called jockle podcast where I
talk about really talk about human
nature through the lens of leadership
and war and general atrocities and
struggle other than human beings go
through so it's a little bit of a rough
podcast to listen to from time to time
but there's a lot of lotta lessons in it
yeah I mean it's uh it really contrasts
from the average podcast in the sense
that it's sort of like you reading a
book every single week or every other
week and just going through giving notes
giving notes based on your experience
yeah it's it's interesting too because I
get most of the books that I try and use
our first-person accounts right of these
situations so whether it's war whether
it's some kind of atrocity it's a
first-person account with someone that
was actually there it's not an
interpretation it's not what someone
else thought that person thought it's
what that person thought so I think that
has the ability to take you into the
minds of and see some of that stuff
through a better perspective and the
more you the more the more different
perspectives you can get other than your
own the better you're going to
understand things yeah yeah I've been
blown away by like I mean the likes the
podcast has when you start it off as I I
don't know if he's gonna be able to find
50 books and now well I fought that too
because when I started there was a few
books you know about faced by Hackworth
there was there was three or four books
that I knew I could cover that really
had a big impact on me and then I then I
reached a little bit and I said we know
I can do this one too and when I started
reading
with the thought that what what can I
learn from this not just not just what
do I understand about it what can I
actually learn from this then I started
pulling out all these old books that I
had read with the old breed just just
books that are incredible books and as I
pulled those out and now I realize the
actual problem isn't that there aren't
enough books the actual problem is that
there's no possible way I can cover all
the books that exist that we can learn
from and that I can learn from so the
the problem ended up not being the
problem my father initially was there's
a lot of incredible books out there yeah
well you're doing a great job Mike
what's your story a much long the same
lines first off thanks for having me on
Y Combinator's dear to my heart because
I was born and raised in Silicon Valley
much like Jack I did something
uncharacteristic to a kid coming out of
Atherton California
I enlisted the Marine Corps and then
eventually became a seal and you know
finished up and retired after 20 years
I was one of Jacko's guys you know in
the book extreme ownership it's all
about the Battle of Ramadi I wasn't one
of those guys I worked for uh for Jocko
and hence how we you know how we've
known each other for for so long
you know I did not write a book because
I believe in an extreme ownership we
can't replicate what is already working
but really you know I finished my MBA at
the University of Texas right before I
retired and I just got into facilitating
successful veteran transitions and when
I say successful a lot of the time that
is not setting the expectation on the
corporate side that is actually setting
the expectation side or setting the
expectations on the veteran side and
getting their heads right it's not an
easy thing to hear after 20 years in the
military that you are a new guy again
but you are you may have some great
leadership tenants and foundational
aspects of leadership but when you step
into a different industry you step into
a different industry and it takes time
you got to roll your sleeves up you've
got to get to work and you've got to
prove your worth mm-hmm and so sometimes
that's a lot tougher for veterans then
then the general public may know mm-hmm
and I mean that's really at the core of
what we were going to talk about today
and so how do
process go for both of you I mean Mike
you you got red and going while you were
still active right I did I still don't
know if that was the right decision you
know when you when you're not coming
from a totally stable financial position
you're still active duty starting a
company even though this was a even
though it was a social venture if the
timing might not have been right but in
retrospect it is a organization that's
gonna do a lot of good for veterans and
so you know I focused my MBA and let me
say that's when I stepped into the MBA
program I thought I was going to do
Investment Banking and I realized really
quickly that that did not play to my
strengths and that I like to create
things in front of me and I like to see
the value proposition as I stand it up
in quickly transition to focusing
because there was a lot of teammates
calling me that
we're like Mike did we know you have
connections in Silicon Valley can you
help me get a job and I'm like did what
is going on here I'm like these are in
jock who knows a lot of these yet these
guys are like amazing amazing leaders so
what is the major disconnect and that's
you know when I got Admiral McRaven
involved and we discussed the the
systemic challenging systemic challenges
facing veterans and really started the
foundation of what vetted came from
which was a research project into those
challenges facing veterans and then the
so what how do we solve it mm-hmm and
that's when we got Wharton UT McCombs
and Texas A&M is person school involved
and hence we created what huffington
post is called the most comprehensive
veteran transition program in the nation
and and now you guys are starting it
here to some extent so yes we basically
we did the social side and in Jocko and
Lafe have been involved in in vetted and
now it's all those lessons learned from
standing that up and we're capitalizing
it in you know we live in the
capitalistic society we can do a lot
more good on the for-profit side than we
can on the nonprofit side right we
didn't want to let those this valuable
lessons from standing this thing up just
go to waste when we knew we could we
could actually shake a lot more cages
and rattle things loose in the
for-profit room because your story Jocko
you when you transitioned out is that
one echelon front began or did you think
about finding a job
somewhere know so about six months
before I retired and my last job in the
Navy was was running the training for
the West Coast SEAL team some really
what I was doing was simulating combat
and then putting leaders through
leadership training that's what it was
and so about six months prior to
retiring a guy that I knew asked me to
come and talk to his executive team
about combat leadership and I thought
you know okay cool I'll go do that and
he said I'll give you some money and I
said well that's makes it even a little
bit cooler so I went up and I talked and
I don't know what he expected me to talk
about but whatever I do you know I
basically gave the same brief that I
would give the young junior officers
when they were entering the SEAL Teams
when they had graduated the the basic
SEAL training I would give him a brief
and I basically gave that same
leadership brief to to these executives
and when I got done the CEO came up to
me and said hey I want you to do this
for every division of my company and I
said well you know I'm retiring in six
months and I'm not really looking to do
anything like that and he says I'll give
you money and I said well okay let's
talk about that then and so then he
ended up paying me and and at one of
those divisional meetings the CEO of the
parent company was there and when I got
done the CEO of the parent company came
up to me and he said hey I want you to
do this for all my CEOs I want you come
talk to all my CEOs and they owned a 45
or 50 companies at the time so I did an
event with 45 or 50 CEOs and got done
with that and a bunch of those CEOs came
up and said to me hey can you come and
talk to my company and and that was
where it started it didn't take very
long for me to be signed up with work
and at the same time Lafe who wrote the
book with me and who was also an ahmadi
and you know my dear friend and brother
he had he was still in the Navy and he
had met with a company that had come to
do like a tour of the SEAL team and they
they kind of were interested as well and
he kind of talked about leadership with
them and as soon as he was getting ready
to get out he got out of 13 years I
think I said hey man I need some fire
support over here and so that's that's
where that's where it started and and
then like you said you know as we would
go out and work with these companies
they'd say hey do you have these you
guys have this stuff written down
anywhere do you have a document you can
give us or a manual you can give us and
eventually we wrote we wrote that the
stuff down more specifically and
that's what turned into the book okay so
I think we should explain like basically
how the transition process works from I
mean the seals of the Navy are more
broadly because I didn't fully
understand the amount of training or the
lack of amount of training that you got
so I think most of our listeners don't
know either
so could you walk through what you get
so you know you announce you're retiring
what happens I don't think I'm really a
great example I think Mike could be
better because I I told my chain of
command that I was retiring you know and
I had great relationships up my chain of
command and it was a whole very hard
decision to make but I told him I was
retiring and then I finished out my my
work and then I went this is going
sector I didn't even go to the there's a
class called tap transit I didn't even
go to that I went to zero so I got I
didn't do anything and I wouldn't
recommend that there's a lot of there's
a lot of good information by the time I
was retiring I well I was pretty much
just good to go and on another path
moving down this road and didn't need to
do anything else I need to do what I
need to do is go forward and continue to
work with civilian leaders and expand
working with more companies so that's
what I did I'm not a great example of
how to set yourself up for retirement or
how the Navy transitions you for
retirement yeah I could actually provide
us some context for that so you know for
your average invite when I mean average
it's not average in town mister your
general soldier airman sailor marine
when you make the decision to get out
you know the military starts you on the
process unfortunately you're pretty much
focused on your work almost up to the
day you get out that's just how the
military is raised and because you want
to do such a good job and you want to
pass off a good product whoever's coming
behind you to ensure their success
that's that's what vets do and so you
focus very little on your actual
transition and then all of a sudden you
get a exiting document from the the
military and you're like what do I do
now so the military does a really good
job of training people on the front end
I mean for the seal community we'll use
that as an example I mean you go through
basically two years
training before you even show up to a
SEAL team you know very specifically I
had to do your job you know the science
of it and of course over the the course
to your SEAL career you hone the art the
military doesn't do a great job of
transitioning people out and preparing
them for success what they did was
outsource the process to the Department
of Labor
hence this transition assistance program
called taps it's a one-week course and
even though taps are run by awesome
awesome Americans this is the way I put
it we have people in the Department of
Labor running those programs that have
very little private sector time
themselves their federal government
employees so federal government
employees should not be preparing
veterans for jobs in the private sector
and that's why we stood up that it and
taps is a basically cursory program that
covers you know all your VA benefits
here are some sources for how to do
resume this is how you should interview
but it's it's very quick and the
Department of Labor does very well with
the problems that they were handed it
just as a whole were were under serving
our veterans and preparing them for
successful transitions and that's why we
need to rely more on the private sector
to get involved and actually solve it
for the government at the end of the day
the military needs to focus on what's
important that is winning wars if we
want the military to get good at
transitioning veterans out that draws
resources from elsewhere which means
we're sending less prepared soldiers
airmen Marines and sailors overseas to
face the threats that they have to face
so again you know if people think well
the military should do a better job of
this it's not all on the military I know
the military has their job their real
job which is to defend this country and
to take focus away from that just it's
not the right thing to do right so
you're stepping in and trying to like
solve this mismatch of Education right
between the private market and military
and so what what does the current
program look like for you guys so we you
know the name of the company that we
unveil in July force is s laun front
overwatch we call it overwatch for for
short is again it's very niche it's a
white glove premium service we focus
specifically
the special operations forces that is
your Green Berets your Navy SEALs your
MARSOC Raiders Air Force PJ's
pararescueman CCT and then combat
aviators so we had to start with a small
group nail that market and then maybe we
can expand down the road to all veterans
because we're not saying that soft and
combat aviators are you know the only
ones that are gonna be successful in the
private sector and there's a lot of
cases that actually defy that so we
focus on those those groups we do a lot
of preparation on the front side
preparing our candidates one the vetting
process Jaco and I are going to tell you
like our industry in the military is
much like any industry you have high
performers those middle road performers
in the sub substandard performers
special on front overwatch will not
place any one that is substandard in any
company because we at the end of the day
are concerned about our credibility in
the private sector so we put a lot of
diligence into preparing and vetting the
candidates that we present to our our
clients now we are industry agnostic it
could be Investment Banking it could be
tech it could be health care you know
ultimately that's know or think they
know what they want to do when they get
out so that's why will place in in any
industry but we do have a thorough
process to vet them and prepare them and
we do put a lot of the work on veterans
you know our golden rule on the website
is no one will own your transition for
you not even us we should you have to
own this we are not going to you know
completely do your resume for you will
revise it but if you're not willing to
roll your sleeves up especially here's
the key not willing to be humble and not
willing to work hard then this is not
for you and so every candidate we
produce is going to be a one established
leader in the military is humble is
ready to work they're ready to listen to
somebody in that industry and learn the
tools of the trade and then apply to
leadership they learn the military to
succeed mm-hmm and are you applying any
particular like educational regimen for
them we are so you know actually I'm
pretty proud of the the career resources
page on the H alone for an overwatch if
you go to EF overwatch comm under the
career resources tab we
laid out a six step process yeah for
veterans to follow and it starts with
know thyself a lot of personal
assessments you know you know we always
talk about soo in front brutal self
assessments to know your strengths know
your weaknesses specifically to play to
your strengths and know how to augment
your your weaknesses and then it goes
from there of re-educating yourself one
doing a lot of career in industry and
research to identify if a certain
industry or company is a right fit
that's on them and then education and
Retraining there's a lot of great
programs out there vetted the venture
and accelerated management program
Stanford ignite right in your backyard
Dartmouth next step Bethany coats with
brake line I mean there's a lot of great
programs don't go through one of them go
through as many as you can
and the one thing you know about vets is
you know we do lack a business acumen we
come from a different industry where we
have a completely set set of tools yeah
in fort you know if I took a CEO from a
tech company in Silicon Valley they
would be blown away watching us go
through the military decision-making
process and how diligent it is so for
vets they have to learn the hard skills
in the new industry they're stepping
into and that's one of the things when
working with clients and we place a
candidate into that company is we lay
out all the steps they need to sort of
retrain themselves to learn those tools
so if they're stepping into digital
marketing we're gonna you know lay out a
number of digital marketing courses that
they can take when they step into the
job so there it's on-the-job training
and again that that overwatch phase of
maintaining contact with the candidate
and client the one thing and simply
learn in your your back yard in August
we are unveiling the corporate skills
apprenticeship program for veterans and
simply learned an echelon front
overwatch are spearheading this it'll
include digital marketing digital
selling PMP Lean Six Sigma so process
improvement agile and then also business
analyst certifications it is tough it is
long but we got a great discount for
veterans and if someone goes through the
other program there is no doubt that
they're you know starting salary with
all those certifications will go up it's
just hey here's the thing you
have to be willing to sit down in stit
and do the work and get through that
corporate skills apprenticeship program
but it's worthwhile so we're happy about
that yeah I mean I can imagine it's
tough if guys are coming out of what 4d
when did you guys get out yeah I was 38
yeah you were 38 yeah no kidding I was
uh well I enlisted in when I was 18 yeah
I was it was nineteen when I enlisted I
got out of it actually no I was I was 39
I just turned 39 because I I did a
little bit over 20 years
okay got it yeah I do so I I got out at
40 enlisted when I was uh 19 but not I
mean we have veterans getting out at all
stages that guys in their younger 20s
that just do you know four to six years
and then guys that do more than us
getting out in their 50s right and guess
what they want to get after it in the
private sector oh yeah I'm sure I mean
they have a whole life ahead of him yeah
and the thing is as Mike was talking
about like sure there's there's skills
that you have to learn for these
specific industries and quite honestly
that's the easy part like if you blow it
off it'll it'll it'll crush you but if
you are attentive to it and you address
it you'll you'll get those skills but
the hard part that people need and what
makes this program great is that you've
got people that have experienced in
leadership and experience leading other
human beings to accomplish very
challenging missions over short periods
of time and over long periods of time
and that is what is challenging and it's
much harder to train someone to be a
leader than it is to train someone about
some technical aspect of a job or even
the background of a job it's it takes
much more time it takes years it takes
dozens of years and that's what we've
got in this situation we've got people
that have not only learned those
leadership skills they've applied those
leadership skills over and over again in
high stress environments there's no
better way we could prepare people for
leadership in the civilian sector then
have them serve in the military and
being leadership positions and then you
take them out you polish them up with
the industry knowledge which again hey
I'm not taking anything away from the
industry knowledge it's important and
it's it's hard to learn but the level
that a leader needs to learn it isn't
the same level that the
ground troop needs to know it so they
they acquire the skill set and then
they've they apply what they've got from
the military and what they've got them
from their leadership experience and
you've got a winner right there
yeah well times Mike said before you
know it's this practiced experience as
compared to an MBA which is to you I
mean like two months into your MBA
you're looking for your internship which
hopefully is your next job yeah I agree
with you the thing about leadership in
you know the executive development
industry is the year-over-year growth is
amazing because companies realize they
have to train their internal talent they
have to build talent from within is that
you know at the end of the day the US
military and we talked about this before
is the preeminent leadership training
platform in the world because we have
the resources and the time to do it I
mean if you step into the military
whether you enlist or you're an officer
you're going through an initial
three-month 24/7 restructuring program
the training program to get you ready
for the rigors of the military in one to
lead and you know Officer Candidate
School and in boot camp so that I mean
there's a methodology to the design and
we talked about this yesterday you know
the Marine Corps is probably the best at
putting people through marine boot camp
interning young girls and boys into men
and women and it's amazing that process
has just not been replicated by anyone
yeah yeah and it's it's the whole thing
with with leadership is that it takes
time it takes time to develop those
skills and the other thing is it's it's
it's hard it's hard to do and you've got
all these crazy people that work for you
know regardless of what situation you're
in you know that's one thing one of the
one of the myths about the military's
that everyone in the military is just uh
they're like robots and they'll just
listen to what everyone says well the
fact that matter is that's that's not
true and even and even even inside the
SEAL Teams I don't think so these guys
are just so motivated they'll do
whatever you say that's completely
untrue the guys in the SEAL Teams you've
got all kinds of just like any other
group of people
you got egos you got personalities
you've got different motivations that
are driving people you got people that
get
get wrapped around their own plan that
they come up with and they don't want to
listen anyone else or it's you have to
work through all those problems so
people that have experience doing that
over time you can't you can't buy that
experience you can't go to school for
that experience and even the fact that
the military takes people and puts you
through leadership training that right
there alone isn't enough what really
makes the people in the military get
become good leaders is that they lead
they lead and may succeed sometimes and
they fail sometimes and if they go
through their career they learn from
those failures and they become better
and they don't make those mistakes again
and by the time they're getting ready to
move on mm-hmm they know what they're
doing mmm-hmm so I think many people are
actually given the success of your
podcast think that when someone comes
out of the sea oh sorry oh it's a joke
Oh or it's a mic like oh we just got one
of those guys but that's not always the
case and I think because so as a
percentage of the population so few
people know any of these elite members
of the service there are these
preconceptions that people get in their
head and I think now's a good time to
just like dispel those and honestly like
explain what people are expecting so
when you guys are talking to an employer
what are you coaching them with how are
you instructing them to like this is
what's reality and this is what you may
think what what comes up well you got
individuals first of all and just like
just like any group of people it's a
bell curve right and just like Mike just
talked about you got people too high
under the bell curve you got people too
low end of the bell curve and you got a
bunch of people in the middle of a bell
curve and our job before we play someone
is to make sure that they're at the high
end of the bell curve mm-hmm because
there's your 100 percent right and we'll
talk about seals for example as far as
someone that's in the civilian sector a
seal is a seal is a seal is a seal if
you if you were in the SEAL Teams you're
good to go you're you're just a perfect
leader and you're a great you've got a
great way to deal with stress and you
can overcome all these problems it's
like that's that's actually not true
there's a lot of great guys in the SEAL
Teams and there's some spectacular
individuals in the SEAL Teams and
there's also guys there's a bunch of
people down the middle that do their job
and they do a great job and then there's
people on the low end of the spectrum
that they don't do a good job and they
managed to stay in then
is true with the Marine Corps true with
the army it's true it's special force
true with everyone every group has their
they're bottom-feeders in there and so
what we do is make sure that something
known of those bond bottom-feeders get
placed by us because it's very hard for
a civilian to tell the difference
between you know I always ask I always
ask employers us have you ever
interviewed somebody and you thought I
am about to hire the biggest stud who's
gonna crush this and I'm set for life
because I got this guy coming by team or
this girl coming on my team and then how
often does that person turn out to be
horrible mm-hmm you know okay let's say
you're pretty good even if you're pretty
good at judging those situations you're
still probably only batting like 70 or
80% at best
20% of time you're hiring someone that
is a disaster people learn to interview
well some people can interview very well
some people some people are great
workers but they interview horribly and
you can't tell from looking at the
resume when you shouldn't talk to me I
don't see this guy this guy or girl
working out so it's the same thing with
the SEAL Teams it's the same thing with
any group any group it's not just the
SEAL Teams any group and so what we're
doing is is taking a look at these
people we're vetting them we're making
sure that we're screening them properly
and know and understand their reputation
through our connections and then train
them and test them and make sure that
they are on board and and think the way
we think and are gonna be a good fit for
well replacement yeah I think Jocko
pretty much summarized that that pretty
well we do get a lot of preconceived
notions naturally people's perceptions
of the military come out of the books
okay in the movies primarily the movies
and so you know a lot of people will
think we just run around the bases
singing Cadence's 24/7 carry logs all
day it's not the case in these guys are
personally authentic they're usually of
high emotional intelligence they're
highly capable they have a character the
aptitude and if they don't even within
our respective communities again we're
using the seal community we tend to
minimize those those bottom feeders as
jackal referred to them if they are
bipolar and just have low emotional
intelligence we're let go
okay yes we're gonna shift you over to
this job here because you know you can
do this job well and it's not on the
front line and it won't have any major
consequences if I mean that happens
within our community as well but we know
and here's the great thing about the
Special Operations community in the
combat aviators is we can reach back to
our respective colleagues that are still
in community and say hey John Doe
thumbs-up thumbs-down oh yeah absolutely
comes up or hey your thumbs down here's
why and we can validate you know that
would pretty pretty quickly so at the
end of the day you know I tell a lot of
employers like hey we don't even charge
a retainer like a lot of recruiting
firms we just want promised interviews
so if a company comes to us we're not
gonna charge it for a retainer fee just
give us three promised interviews and we
want the dates and times and we'll put
our candidates in front of you and then
they they impress them like oh wow
totally demystified what I thought about
Veterans yeah we know we know and that
changes a lot of perceptions you just
got to talk to him
and you recognize hey these are people
too so for those who aren't fortunate
enough to work with you guys do you have
some advice for companies interviewing
veterans or looking to interview
veterans this is a question that's comes
up all the time it comes up from every
company I work with and it came up in
the SEAL Teams and you've probably heard
me talk about this it's like guess what
it's really hard to judge people it's
really hard to judge people it's really
hard to judge a book by a cover and we
you know I I was in you you watch people
going to the basic SEAL training course
and you look at a group of ten people
and you not gonna know who's gonna make
it through who's not gonna make it
through that's the way it is the only
way to figure out who's gonna make it
through to put them through it yeah
that's the only way now so what I'd
recommend a companies all the time is
when you you know yes you want to do a
thorough interview yes you want to give
them scenarios yes you want to put some
pressure on them and figure out where
they're coming from but what you really
want to do is say look we're gonna bring
you on as a contractor for 90 days and
see what you're like see what you're
like and see if you can really do what
it is you say you can do and see if
you're gonna lose your temper and see if
you're gonna get crazy on
some my new thing that doesn't really
matter and see if you're gonna work hard
like all those things are things that
you need to explore when you're dealing
with a hiring situation yeah so like
standard best practices yeah stratum
like anyone else standard best practices
gold standard precious I mean you could
the only thing I'd say is when you when
you do have a veteran and or you're
looking to hire a veteran again going
back to the technical skills that they
may or may not have that's ok take a
look at the technical skills and say you
know what are they in the ballpark and
can we give them a little bit of
leniency because we know that they've
got some experience and some leadership
skills that we can bring the table and
they've got some discipline and they've
got some some people skills that they
can under the table so all those are all
those are good things so one of the
services it's worth mentioning that you
know basically this this test drive
before you make a final offer we
actually will work with companies to set
up a veteran fellowship for recently
separated veterans so they get this
great veteran for anywhere from 6 months
to 12 years at a industry standard
salary as a fellowship hooking in there
and then they get to make that final
determination at the end of the 6 months
or 12 months of yes this is a good
candidate for this company we want to
make a final offer and then what it
allows veterans to do as well sort of
you know the all tourism of the side of
the company is you're giving them great
industry experience where they can come
back to us and we can find another
company that is a right culture fit so
it really benefits both parties great
let's go a little bit broader so Jocko
you've been on a warpath writing in the
past couple years
sure I'm curious about the next book so
dichotomy of leadership dichotomy in
leadership this is another one I'm
writing with we actually wrote it's
worth it's worth Lafe once again and the
title is dichotomy leadership and so as
as which is actually chapter 12 in
extreme ownership is called the
dichotomy leadership and the reason for
that is the reason that we ended up
writing a whole book about it now is as
we work with companies over the past
years and we look and see what what
problems were they having where were the
issues that they were having
it was always trying to find this
balance in the various dichotomies of
leadership of which there is I think in
infinite numbers number so for instance
as a leader if you go too far in one
direction you become a micromanager hmm
and now your people lose any initiative
and they stop taking charge of things
and they stop they stop moving forward
without your permission
so you're micromanaging them too much
and that's bad you go too far in the
other direction where now they they
don't they don't even know what your
strategy is you don't communicate with
them enough they don't know which
direction they're supposed to be heading
and they're all kind of wandering around
that's bad so what you have to do is you
have to balance those two is it possible
for a leader to be too close to your
people where all of a sudden you develop
these close relationships where they
stop listening to you because now you
become more of a friend than a leader or
is it possible so that's bad or or you
go too far in the other direction where
you don't know who anyone is and you
don't know what their what's going on
with their family life and you can't
relate to them at all well then that's
bad as well so there's all these
dichotomies that you as a leader have to
balance and it's it's the hardest thing
to do as a leader because you but
because the reason is because both
answers are right both it like is it
right to be close to your people yeah
absolutely
so you should be close to them but is it
right to like have enough distance that
they still it yes that's right too so
that every direction is the right answer
but what you have to do is balance them
and so that's why we wrote this entire
book about all well many of these
dichotomies that exist and and then once
you recognize that there are dichotomies
and then you can start seeing them and
everything you know there's ones that we
didn't write in the book that you know
we still tweet we mentioned in the book
we didn't write whole chapters about
them but you know is it possible to be
too direct and communicating with
someone well yes it is because you can
be offensive to them is it possible to
not be direct enough yes it is because
now they don't really understand what it
is you want yeah so these dichotomies
exist everywhere as a leader and that's
why we ended up and as we dealt with
companies and we saw where that where
the friction points were it was always
because they were getting off they were
losing the balance in various categories
of leadership and that's why we wrote
the whole book about it what are the
dichotomies you
deal with and managing each other and
working together you know in all of us
weren't you too well I would say that
the biggest thing for me is you know I'm
pretty hands-off you know and I give
intent on how things are supposed to go
and mike is so so I lean towards being a
little bit too hands-off Mike leans
towards being a little bit too
aggressive and so it's it's the it's
fine but occasionally I I look up and I
see where Mike is not like hey Mike come
back and and that's the way it is but
you know I mean we've been working
together for a long time and you known
each other for a long time
and and that's the way the whole our
whole company of echelon front it's all
you know it's all that's that's the way
we operate we know each other very well
it makes it makes a lot easier that we
don't have to build relationships that
relationships are already there we
already know we already know each
other's strengths and weaknesses and and
whether its strengths and weaknesses or
just like I know Mike's gonna be
aggressive I know if I if I put Mike in
a room with you know like a shovel and a
match I'm gonna come back two weeks
later and he's gonna have like dug to
the you know through the ground and
built a fire and we're creating some
business around whatever right that's
what's gonna happen and that that's
that's fine so I just need to be aware
of that and and then he knows me like he
knows me I'll be like yeah I'll go get
some good go and then occasionally he
goes oh you know what I should probably
tell Joe that I'm about to make this
major move right now yeah whatever and
so and it's the same thing you know
throughout all the whole crew so Mike
I'm curious about your answer but I have
another question for you because this is
how it works with most startups so all
right you you and life start a show on
front right and then you hire like one
buddy
and then you hire two buddies and before
you know it like you're at ten and
you've maybe run out of buddies you want
to hire how do what happens if echelon
front goes to a hundred people or will
you cap it before that happens we won't
cap it wil will hire the right people
that's what that's what we'll do we'll
hire the right people and most important
well there's a bunch of things that are
equally important number one will hire
the right now hire the right people
number two when people come on board
before they come on board we'll make
sure that they understand where we're
coming from once they're on board we'll
make it really really clear how we roll
right okay how we roll how do they say
that the business world they say our
culture right they say this is our
culture like that's how you'd say I'd
say like this is how we roll this is who
we are
yeah this is what we do and when people
get on board and they recognize that
this like this is not a game this is
actually what we do and this is how we
roll then people will either get on
board with the program or they won't
people that don't get on board with the
program that's okay I don't dislike
people that don't get on board with the
program but I'm not gonna work with them
I'm not gonna work with them there's
plenty of people out there that want to
work hard and and want to get after it
there's plenty of people out there
there's also plenty people that don't
and that's okay
we'll bring people on board that want to
get after it right well there's also
different styles of getting after it
okay explain those to me well I mean it
okay so I often break it down into
personality types right so I'm generally
maybe skewing towards Mike's direction
in terms like really getting into
something and then putting my head down
and just doing it so low and I generally
don't require input from other people
once I know is like all right this is
what's happening I'm doing it I prefer
to work alone on this project and I can
get this [ __ ] done
sure yeah you're right other people need
to be affirmed the whole way and those
styles don't necessarily align perfectly
if you build that whole team yeah you're
gonna end up with different types of
people on every team just like I said
earlier so and you are right I I didn't
really understand what you were saying
but yeah there's people that move
forward in different ways and there's
some people and and that's one thing
like for instance with span of control
right it like you know there's a number
for span of control in combat it's four
or five people in the business world
it's seven or eight people generally
those are the numbers that get thrown
around however if you're in control or
if you're if you're running a team and
everyone on the team is a player's guess
what you can control more of them
because you don't have to give them a
correct much direction if you have a
bunch of some substandard players on
your team and guess what they're gonna
need more direction guess what in your
average team some of them are it's a
bell curve and so there's some people
you don't have to give much attention to
you're a guy that puts Craig get this
project down you're gonna get this
project done you put your head down
you're gonna get after it and I know
it's taken care of
bill over here Oh bill can you get this
project done well yeah okay and I know
that bill is gonna need a little
follow-up nothing major but I'm gonna
have to give him a little a little pat
on the back a little nudge to make sure
he's getting his job back yeah
absolutely you have to you have to
modulate your leadership depending on
the people you're dealing with now this
doesn't mean that you change your
personality this doesn't mean you're a
different human being it doesn't mean
you're you're two-faced in any sense but
you have to modulate your interaction
with different people depending on the
type of person that you're dealing with
I think that's in my experience that's
been one of the hardest leadership
problems like not problems or challenges
like just getting used to dealing with
different types of people and
recognizing that like I'm in a
heads-down mode right now but Jaco needs
a lot of help right now and
unfortunately I have to give them time
and again that's one of the best things
about what we're doing now is bringing
people that have dealt with all these
Scituate and dealt with all these
different types of people and they have
learned to recognize these things and so
now we give us some technical skills we
get them out in the field and they in
the crusher man I'm gonna have to
compete with these guys all right Mike
what are the dichotomies that you think
you deal with with Jocko I want to go
back to it you know this is easy here in
Jocko alluded to it we've built trust
and credibility in Jacko's eyes since
2006 so what I view as LAN front ass is
basically task unit bruiser from the
Battle of rod Ramadi rebranded so when
you just talked about it who we are and
how we roll him when Jocko MAIF came to
me they're like um onboarding
it's like okay I already know who we are
and how we roll and I mean they threw me
into the next pretty quick I did one
event without with Jocko one of that
with life and they're like go forth now
and perform it in with Jocko and you
know Jocko was again the the tasking and
commander to us all memmer to us all
it's easy
and you know with Jocko it's one thing
perform do your job and do well I know
you have to capability to do it and
utilize the the principles of extreme
ownership and the laws of combat and you
will succeed
it doesn't mean we will not I mean we
will fail here and there but the great
thing about like Jocko and tasking
bruisers there was no zero defect
mentality as I like to call it we are
not perfect we are flawed like every
other other human we will fail and then
we will sit down we'll learn from it so
that we never make that mistake again
and one of the best the best military
unit I ever worked for bar none was task
unit bruiser and I never saw a level of
humility within the military by tasking
and preserver ever again so and that was
really my military career when I was 8
years into the military at that point
yeah and that's one thing I did want to
bring up a little bit was when when we
were talking earlier about screening
people right and basically I was saying
like hey we're gonna screen people and
make sure that they're on board and it
makes me sound like I'm sitting here
saying we're the judge of everyone
that's in the military that's absolutely
not true and there's plenty there's
there's so many people in the military
that are far superior in every skill set
that I have ever had even at my absolute
prime we there's there's thousands and
thousands and thousands of people that
are far superior to me in every way and
I'm stoked that I will have the
opportunity to give those people out to
companies where they will go and crush
it because believe me on the same in the
civilian sector I meet leaders all the
time in the civilian sector that are
unbelievably awesome leaders and guess
what they want they want more good
people they want more good people so for
me to have this opportunity really not
not as a judge and I apologize for
coming off like hey I'm judging or we're
judging and we're screening and like no
actually we're looking for people that
are better than us and and I know him I
know him I know people that are better
than all of us and those are the people
were gonna bring
and turn them loose with these companies
again with with companies in the
civilian sector that are incredible
incredible companies with incredible
leadership that want more good people
and you know what there's companies in
the civilian sector that that maybe they
have some leadership issues and this is
something that I saw a lot when I was
running training you have a seal platoon
er you give us feel task unit when I
first started running the training I
wanted the platoon commander and the
platoon chief to be the leaders I was
like these guys and if they weren't the
leaders I would I I thought it was wrong
and it didn't take me long to be it
didn't take me long to get to a point
where war oh it's it's hard to find good
leaders so if I have two good leaders in
a co platoon and to have them actually
be the platoon commander in the platoon
chief was actually ended up being very
very rare and I realized that it didn't
matter that much it was optimal but what
I really wanted was a couple really
solid leaders in the team I didn't care
where they were in the team they could
be the lowest ranking guy they could be
in the middle somewhere they needed to
be good solid leadership and if you had
one or two if you had two really you
need two good leaders if you had two
good leaders and a seal platoon the seal
platoon was gonna do awesome and it
didn't matter where they were if they
happen to be the platoon commander great
if it happened to be the platoon chief
great if it happened to be the leading
petty officer great
that was super if it happened to be an
e5 that had done two deployments to
Afghanistan or Iraq and had a lot of
experience and had stepped up and and
got after it and and was a good leader
he would make things happen yeah and he
would do it in such a way where he
wasn't stepping on people's toes but he
would still get the respect to the boys
it was awesome to see and so when we go
to companies now like people always say
well the CEO is messed up or or my
leaders messed up it's a that's okay
you're gonna work for people that aren't
necessarily the best leaders in the
world that's fine people ask me what do
you do when you have a weak leader I'm
like I'm happy if my leaders weak I'm
stoked I'm going hey boss you know I got
this hey thanks for your support
we're gonna keep over we're gonna keep
we're gonna be over here doing what we
do I'll let you know if we need anything
we really appreciate it
here's the credit on the last things we
did here you take it go make yourself
look great that's what I'm here for and
you build that relationship and you go
get the mission done yeah that's what
you do so again I just want to make sure
that
not sounding like Haworth aware the
supreme judges of the world cuz we're
absolutely not we do happen to be lucky
enough to have contacts in in the
military community and now contacts in
the civilian community and we just want
to help those two great groups of people
get together and kick ass man I think
it's so great howdy how do you recommend
that company set up their structure such
that you know the intern that just
started if they have a great idea let's
ship it it's happening do you have
advice on that
yeah it's called decentralized command
it's called humility right so so
decentralized schematic stream ownership
has the fundamental concept of hey we're
gonna II listen up and down the chain of
command we're gonna let our frontline
people who knows better if Mike's in the
field with his platoon and I'm back in
the in the in if Forward Operating Base
somewhere and he needs to make a
decision
who knows to make a better decisions it
mirrors at him it's him 99.9 percent of
the time there's that small percentage
of the time where I happen to know
because I'm in a I'm in a further away
position that there's enemy Minh moving
in or that there's a support element
coming to him and I can say Mike
don't go west hold what you got there's
a support element coming your direction
right now and he goes okay thank you and
and so but most of the time he's in the
field and he says hey this is what I see
this is what I'm gonna do and I say
awesome do it let me know how we can
support you or here's some elements I'm
gonna move to support you so that's
decentralized command the the biggest
hindrance to decentralized command is
ego is me going
you shut up Mike and do what I tell you
to do you don't know what you're doing
you're junior to me you haven't been as
long as me you've been as long as me you
need to listen to me yeah no actually
I'm stoked when one of my subordinate
leaders comes up with a great plan that
that makes me is that makes me that
makes me eminently happy because now I
can say Oh Mike that's a great plan you
know what I couldn't come up with that
plan you run an executed now who has
ownership of that plan it's all Mike and
he's gonna run with that plan he's gonna
make it work he's gonna overcome any
obstacles that's what's gonna happen
why because he he created the plan it's
his plan as opposed
me dictating a plan to him and saying
this is the way you will do it you won't
deviate from what I've told you to do
well then what's he gonna do when he
gets out in the field and hits an
obstacle he's gonna go oh you know what
jock was planned socking we're not gonna
go that way you know you set up a
culture like that we're even the new guy
yeah we're his or her opinion matters
then you set up a culture for success
and I'll tell you why and I'm gonna
refer back to the task unit bruiser they
set up front that day even if you're a
new guy you lead and if everyone's
leading we win and then you fast forward
through that with the one year of
training that we had leading up to the
Battle of Ramadi the new guys on their
first deployment within task unit
bruiser were some of the high-performing
individuals within that task unit I mean
the the the accolades that came out of
it you know unfortunately we lost some
new guys Michael Monsoor who made the
most selfless sacrifice by jumping on a
grenade to save three other seals
brand-new guy Ryan Jobe laying down
cover fire for his team to move brand
new guy mark Lee you know killed during
a firefight again covering his uh his
brothers and then you know I can say it
John and Kim because he's uh you know in
the public eye up with Johnny Kim now a
NASA astronaut was a brand new guy who
was awarded the Silver Star during that
during that deployment why because they
set the culture upfront that lead speak
up and leap we're listening no doubt
about it and if you think that me okay
because I was in charge of tasking your
prisoner if you think that I can sit
there in any combat situation and
control like a puppet master the
elements that are out on the battlefield
it's just it's it's literally impossible
to I don't care who you are I don't care
how good you are you don't have the
cognitive capacity to do that and it
happens in businesses and again this is
this is did we see this all the time in
businesses as the businesses grow you
talked about going from ten people to
hundred people
well if you've got a CEO that's a good
solid leader and he likes to control
things with
and people he can pull it off for sure
with pet ten people he can pull it off
he's a workaholic he's working 22 hours
a day 20 hours a day 18 hours a day he's
on he's in every meeting he can he can
pull that off when he gets 200 people
you can't pull that off anymore there's
it's it's physically humanly and
cognitively impossible to do that so if
he hasn't or she hasn't set up the
culture strong enough that people
understand how they're supposed to
operate then they're not going to
operate properly so you know that's
that's that's real commander's intent
and it is its culture commander's intent
is or a culture is almost like a broad
commander's intent that overlays the
entire the entire group of individuals
that you work with everybody knows
everybody knows this is what wouldn't
leak this is what we're moving towards
right so with this new book are you
referencing stories from echelon front
because I've kind of been wondering if
the podcast is now gonna create a
feedback loop so you're you're maybe not
this book but maybe the next book is
actually not even your stories but it's
stories from Vietnam World War two
so I the the next book dichotomy of
leadership is still stories from our
military yeah
career from our combat experiences and
from the training that we went through
and it also does still include stories
from echelon from from all the companies
that we've worked with down the line
yeah there will be other books that
address other things learners that I've
learned from the podcast yeah so I've
I've got that book probably coming out
about a year after this one so I've
already done that deal yeah dude yeah
how many hours a day do you write I
write I try write an hour a day when
it's on
so I write about a thousand words an
hour and I sit down and write for now
and I got a thousand words so you know
for for the kids book they're about
twenty-five or thirty thousand words so
that's that's 30 days 25 or 30 days
worth of writing a thousand words that
you keep every day yeah I I do pretty
it's out of the goat nice I do pretty
decent out of gate as a matter of fact
though the second warrior kid book I
write when I was about to finish it I
probably had another 5,000 words to
finish and it was just through the first
draft and I had some stuff go on where I
could I just had to finish it and I
submitted it and it was almost it was
almost good to go as well with very few
edits on the first literally the front
like normally I would would have edited
edited it three or four times I I did
not edit it I edited it once it got back
you know they get back to me but yeah so
I write I write Hardin yeah do I throw
stuff out sometimes absolutely but even
if you write a thousand words when you
throw out 400 guess what you got 600
words yeah yeah here cookin and in and
in two or three months you got 50 or
60,000 words and you're done so it's
it's a it's a good little system the
other thing about it
for anyone that's interested in writing
you probably you are but if you write
every day you don't have to go back and
read which you wrote the previous day
because you still remember it mm-hmm for
me if I take two days so if I write
today and then I don't write tomorrow
and then I go to write again I got to go
back and read that one day is enough for
me to forget really where I was at
whereas if I write today alright
tomorrow I can pick up I can literally
just start typing again because I know
where I was at so if you're gonna do it
that's the disciplined manner to make it
happen
yeah I mean that's like maintaining some
kind of flow state has always been a
challenge for creative projects and may
like I'm so impressed with you guys with
writing the podcast like constantly
doing these muster events like you just
got to stay on it you got to keep the
beat going cuz it's so easy to let it
slip I mean I put what was that event in
New York like how'd that go you know
yeah and I think the other thing is you
have to force if you don't put if you
don't if you don't force it out of
yourself it's not gonna happen if you
don't force it out of yourself is not
gonna have them the book or the project
or the thing that you want to do the
podcast that you're gonna do yeah if you
don't if you don't put discipline around
it it's not going to happen I mean I've
been putting out the podcast for 133
weeks and I've missed one and you know
it's like that's that's pudding there's
a lot of pressure it's a lot of pressure
and you're reading a book and I like a
book you're going back there's a lot to
do it's it's it's no joke and but if I
didn't have the time line then guess
what it's real easy to say you know what
they don't really need one right I don't
really I can I can push this off it's
real easy to do that
it's real easy to do that with
everything in life whether it's a
workout whether it's writing whether
it's a project you're supposed to be
doing whether it's sitting down at a
computer screen to do and learn some
some technical skills that you know is
gonna make you a better a better
candidate for jobs all those little
things it's discipline goes freedom
that's what it is yeah 101 yep
discipline equals freedom 101 are you
guys working on something right now like
what how are you improving yourself I'm
so curious I didn't like I read
discipline equals freedom on the flight
over here was like oh man this is
awesome like I read the book I listened
to the podcast so like I think I get
this but book is great but it's this
framework for life right so whatever it
might be you just apply it are there
specific things because I think I'm I'm
curious about you guys just as men like
things that you are personally working
on right now whether it yeah all
obviously take the first job I'm working
at becoming a better father quite
frankly and people might think that
sounds weird well why aren't you like
trying to push a business for oh no that
that is a requirement we're working 90
hour to 100 hour weeks writing learning
more about a you know talent acquisition
how to solve this systemic challenges
that that is that is gonna happen that's
a requirement but it's how do i balance
my time really well to keep you know my
kids more of my time because in jock and
i have talked about this a lot is when
you're in the military your family comes
second and that might sound harsh but
when you have 40 seals under your
command that are your responsibility to
bring home you know you day usually come
first and I think the families
understand that it's just some of the
unsung heroes in the military are
absolutely the lives and the and the
children and so now that I'm out
I'm trying to you know achieve that
dichotomy within my life to be a better
father
do you have one do I have one no okay
I've got an infinite list of things that
I'm trying to get better at all the time
I'm not getting an infinite list of
things I'm trying to get better at all
the time and that's just the way it is
yeah I hate sucking it's tough and I
suck at all kinds of stuff I'm trying to
get better dude that's the podcast I
keep meeting me people who are just like
the top 1% in their field science
business whatever it is and your son all
right that's a whole lifetime spent
learning physics and yeah just to do the
interview it takes a couple days to grow
you know it's a good thing for guys like
Jaco and I and for anyone in any
industry that wants to be the best it's
more about the process it's not the end
state like I find in it and I'm sure
you'll agree I find very little solace
in in achieving anything it's like okay
teve it yeah immediately no no
celebrating like what's next I just
don't find any gratification but you
know if I look back to the process I'm
like okay that was pretty badass that's
good let's move on to the next thing and
I find that amongst high high performers
high achievers is that they're just
never satisfied with the end state it's
all about the process yeah what's next
dude it's so important to get good at
something too
because i've tying on to that like
before i had gotten really really good
at something i didn't fully understand
that process and what it feels like and
then you just apply it to something else
what are you really really good at I
have a cycling world record so I'm
pretty good at riding bikes yeah yeah it
was a two days straight climbing up and
down a hill so it's most elevation in
two days so yeah but once you do but it
was the same thing man like it wrapped
up and like all right dude is amazing
it's so cool like you're in the Guinness
Book World Records that's awesome
exactly exactly and like you know
there's someone chomping at your heels
so yeah okay I've got to say this is why
you would love the guys we place in your
companies it's like the one thing about
the teams that I loved is it was the
competition made the world your
I'm like if Jocko like you know could
shoot a target ten times within ten
seconds it was like I would be there all
day until I could get nine seconds and
then he'd hear that nine second it
creates this culture of you know
everyone gets along they realize the
competition makes everyone better that
was the great thing about the SEAL Teams
everything is a competition yeah yeah
well it's cool you're surrounded by them
still guys we got a bunch of questions
for you from the internet shall we
alright so first question Alex but
medallion asks what are some military
tactics startups could adopt to increase
effectiveness and throughput yeah we
covered at corner yeah I mean but right
there it's a cover move is the first
thing I think about because if we're not
supporting each other then we're not
gonna be able to get things done that we
need to get done so work cover and move
means teamwork work together as a team
and I actually just had this with this
discussion with a group a company and
they had they had reordered and put
simple as the first law of combat and I
kind of joked around it was that it was
the the president that had done this and
I joked around them and I said hey
there's he said we I did it cuz it
looked good on this graphic and I go
it's cool I get it that looks gonna
graphic but the reality is they are in
an order of of cover movies number one
and the reason cover movies number one
is because that's teamwork and if we're
not working together there's there's
what we're not moving forward we're not
gonna be effective we're not gonna be
efficient so when you look at what your
mission is and you look at your
submission that's nested inside the
greater message don't just focus on that
make sure you look as a company like how
are we gonna help the other elements
that are inside of our team how we can
help them move forward
don't just worry about yourself worry
about everyone that's covered move I
would go one further take the laws of
combat cover and move simple prioritize
and execute decentralized command and
actually post it up on your wall
basically why I love startups is it's
the fire team you all you have limited
resources you have a small team everyone
has more
to pull multiple tasks to do and you
have a burn rate that you have to manage
and to increase that 30 the throughput
and drive revenue as quickly as possible
I mean the laws of combat if you
reinforce this within your company it
will work if you truly understand what
they mean as a small team you implement
them you will succeed right on next
question
all right Allen asks hey joko from your
experience in Sealand as a CEO in
business in the business world do two or
more co-founders leaders have a higher
success rate what are your thoughts on a
solo founder with a strong team rather a
solo founder creating their own strong
team I think it's a little strange to
think about someone doing something solo
and achieving anything really incredible
you're gonna need a team you're gonna
need people and the more you trust your
team and the better relationship you
have with your team then the the better
you're gonna do so I think if you're a
good I think the critical thing here is
you have to you have to think about what
you're gonna do you have to think about
what you're gonna do and how you're
gonna get it done if you're if you're if
you think you can accomplish things by
yourself
you're probably a little bit mistaken
you you might even be a lot mistaken if
you think you've got every if you think
you know everything better than everyone
else and that's why you should control
everything it's probably gonna end up
problematic to have somebody that's a
good sounding board is important now the
other thing I would say about this is
it's also important to find people and
work with people that compliment who you
are that compliment your your your
strengths and your weaknesses if you're
a person that has great ideas but is bad
at execution you need to find a partner
that's really good at execution if you
go out and find a partner that also has
incredible ideas and and you to put this
company together and it's filled with a
bunch of ideas guess what no one's gonna
execute those ideas you're not gonna go
anywhere if you're a person that can
execute well but maybe you don't have
some of those creative thought processes
you find someone that's got good
creative thought process so
you want to partner with people
absolutely and you want to partner with
people that making you better in court
of that and half before that is kind of
like seeing the world as it is that's a
problem I see with a lot of solo
founders they're just like I got this
figured out and then they're a little
bit delusional we see that in the
military all time in it we called
emotional attachment so you know I would
sit and chocolate pass hey we need to
actually give this mission go ahead and
plant it and I plan it for three days
and during that process because I think
I'm coming up with this great plan
that's gonna want him and then I present
it and I've been one inch from viewing
the plan for the last three days and
then he comes in from a six foot view
he's like oh good plan but you switch
this this and this and like this will go
wrong if you do it that way and then you
know what I do I lash out and I'm like
yeah yeah usually away from the leaving
that mother but he's right and so the
worst thing you can do is become so
emotionally attached to your product
that you stop listening to who your
customers because in the military we say
the enemy has a as a vote in all plans
so does your customer and so the second
you you've got everything figured out
and you stop listening to your customer
you need to step back
detach emotionally yep and reassess yep
do you guys do that by journaling just
buy it through experience yeah I can
tell you so people ask me about
detachment a lot because I talk about
the debt a lot because detachment is
it's definitely one of the key technical
skills to have as a leader and as a
human being by the way and so there's
all kinds of things and I actually wrote
about it in a the kids book quite a bit
I wrote about how you emotionally detach
because the kid loses his temper and
gets in trouble and guess what you've
gotta learn to detach well guess human
beings do that adults do that all the
time so this idea of detaching is
something that you absolutely have to
focus on how do you do it well you have
to learn to recognize when you are
getting emotional because normally it's
to to detach from the chaotic situation
so there's a there's a if you're on a
construction site and something's going
wrong and you
step back so that you can fix it or
you're in a manufacturing plant and
something's going wrong and you step
back so you can fix it you're stepping
away from it physically that's that's
good
there's also situations where you need
to step away emotionally and that's a
little bit harder and you know the
examples that I talked about me first of
all if you start your voice starts
getting like this well that's you need
to put yourself in check you you're
obviously getting emotional you also if
you if you're getting ready to send an
email and you're typing really hard on
it that's probably not a good email to
send you should you should wait 24 hours
before you send that that email up the
chain of command and then there's this
part and this is probably this is the
one that is most valuable when you're
looking at a situation and you're
feeling the anger the frustration things
aren't going the way they're supposed to
go much of the time you need to step
back and you need to look at yourself
and figure out why you are getting
emotional and most of the time I would
venture to guess the reason that you're
getting emotional the reason they're
getting mad is because of your own ego
someone has done something that's
offended your ego someone has come up
with a plan that's better than yours
someone has come up with an idea that's
better than yours someone has has dared
to to confront something that you've
said when you should not be questioned
and those ego flare-ups caused all kinds
of emotions and so if you don't learn to
detach from those and do real
assessments and figure out object lean
otta motional II what the problem is
then you will have some significant
issues so learn to detach yeah I mean
oftentimes the people that yeah when I
was growing up the people that bugged me
the most had a quality that I didn't
have or wanted to have more of and then
you're saying oh that guy is more
articulate or he's stronger or whatever
it is yeah and that was it to a tee
welcome welcome to my life Greg all
right next question let's see Armando
Novus asked two Jocko
I liked your episode strategy and the
way of the samurai I think that was Tim
Ferriss right
so I did one with Tim Ferriss that was
based on the novel Musashi which is a
which is an incredible incredible novel
and it's it's a historical fiction based
on the life of the great Japanese
swordsman Musashi
and then Musashi is the guy that wrote
the book of five rings and I covered the
book of five rings first before I did
Musashi just so people would have that
background on it before we got into it
but book of five rims book of five rings
is pretty famous I think that was
episode 80 and then the one with Tim was
episode of 100 cool and that one is I
think that's one of the few that's over
four hours long because when I got done
I was joking with Tim Ferriss I was like
well there's the you know he's got the
4-hour workweek in the 4-hour chef and I
was like well there's the for our
podcast totally um and we did it right
after he had gotten out of some some
really psychotic fasting and both of
silence deal so he had been in silence
for allah's sake like ten or fifteen
days some long period of time and it was
awesome was also due to cover that but
yeah that's so that's that's the Musashi
okay great and then his question is how
much does the daily warrior mindset how
much do you implement on a day to day
basis I was thinking earlier when Mike
was talking about the tap program that
gets you out of the military and I was
thinking to myself so you you take a guy
like myself that's been indoctrinated
and then lived and breathed and eaten
and slept nothing but military for 20
years and then you go okay look we're
gonna send you this program for a week
and and that'll get you ready it you
know it's kind of laughable right yeah a
little bit laughable at least it's gonna
take some more transition so for me to
to think that for me to think that I
think about the warrior mindset I don't
it's just part it's just my day it's
just a little what I'm saying I don't
even know other ways to think I don't I
actively engaged because what's that
well the the the statement about the
fish in the water right a David Foster
Wallace David Foster Wallace this is
water this is water that's like me
right I don't even know that I'm in this
I'm just swimming in it and that's just
how as echo Charles says that's just how
you know this is this is the way it is
so I don't actively think about it but
all I've been doing my whole adult life
is this right that's all I read about
that's all I write about that's all I
think about
that's all I do are you equally maniacal
I think so you did you talked about the
perception of that's it is strange it's
there almost is like a negative
connotation I'm like being in the
military those days there is still you
know it was it was it was live in the
Vietnam War you know if like the
military's evil the military's awesome
like it is the foundation of our lives
like hey you know I was a troublesome
kid in Atherton what they did yeah like
my father the father saw it firsthand he
had you know bad experiences during
Vietnam with the army and absolutely
loves the military we love the military
well you know war is a tragic thing but
it also serves some great purposes and
you know we reference and we make every
analogy a military analogy because we
saw that good and actually you know what
the one outcome from echelon front and a
chillon front overwatch is I hope more
kids sign up in the military I honestly
do it is a great platform to take a
young boy or a young girl and turn them
into a outstanding leader but I am
maniacal about my service and the
service of our brothers and sisters man
it was awesome and there's just so much
good they can do yeah outside the
military after they're done whether it's
six years 20 years or 35 years
yeah yeah yeah absolutely right
all right we got a couple more just real
quick cool all right so Ryan calmer Carl
Mercer asks hey life isn't here but I
think this is relevant for all I guess
what's your favorite Emery
I'll put a James Gray MREs are designed
to meet your caloric intake
environments if I had my way would I
take a prime rib yeah
bone-in prime rib out to the field cook
it and eat it yes I would but you know
Ryan you don't see me coming home to my
fiance Jordan saying hey why don't we
cook up some of those MREs that doesn't
that does not happen they are awful but
they are a good tool that when you're in
austere environment yeah you get hungry
enough they're beautiful thing they're
unbelievably delicious when you're you
know you know you haven't eaten for a
while yeah and there's people that get
really good at they basically can cook
with them they basically are not not
cook like they can chef what is that
called
they can create they can create these
little mixtures that make things you
like better like they doctor them up a
little they they they they mix them
together in a certain way and then put
the certain spices with this or whatever
and so there's people that get good at
that I was never one of those people I
was when I was a young enlisted I was a
radio man so I always carried a lot of
weight and I didn't have room to carry
much food and so the only thing I would
carry from MREs was the main meal which
is one pouch like all the other stuff I
didn't bring because it was just too
much stuff yeah and so I just carried
the main meal and as Mike said in a
normal day-to-day life I would not like
one my first deployment to Iraq we ate
way too many MREs and I hated them at
the we only ate them for about a month
and then we started getting some good
better food and so that month I really
didn't like them after that time period
but if you're really hungry man they're
a beautiful thing yeah and to make a
second bike reference they're just
saying from bike touring that's a hunger
is the best seasoning yeah well that's
that's great I always talk about you
know water yeah like if you've never if
you've ever been thirsty before then you
remember how amazing water is water is
beautiful and the only thing that hurts
worse than lack of water is lack of air
and lack of air doesn't last very long
but that feeling is the worst followed
by followed by water and I've never gone
hungry more than you know four or five
days so I'm pretty lucky in that regard
but reading about some of the people
that suffer without food for extended
periods of time no talking to talking to
some of the guys that were in the Hanoi
Hilton living on you know a ball of rice
one in the morning one in the afternoon
for six years you know and losing a
hundred pounds per person it's just
unbelievable and he's also unbelievable
how those guys in that austere situation
would would sit there and talk about
food and hours and hours you know
captain captain Charlie plan was was on
the podcast and just to hear him talk
about you could still see a little light
in his eyes when you talk about good
food and same with bill reader who was
in a horrible situation as well and
ended up in the Royal but to see those
guys you know you go talk to those guys
and you really get to appreciate the
incredible blessings that we have and
how freakin easy our life is yeah and
you realize how much you can suffer
through all right next question
Spencer Clark asks is culture more
decided by micro or macro policies and
interactions I don't think that's a
question that I don't think it's one or
the other I think if you're if you're
behaving on a macro level one way and
then in the micro level you're not
reflecting that that's not gonna wash
out correctly if you're and the opposite
is true so you have to you have to
husband both of those macro and micro
cultures equally and they're both
equally important if you're a guy that
treats everyone at a macro level one way
and then on the frontlines you treat
them a different way yeah guess what
guess what your culture is it's actually
it's actually even worse it'd be better
just to have a hard attitude yeah that
everyone just knew where you came from
but to be two-faced is actually worse so
gotta treat him equally everything
matters if you're in a leadership
position everyone's watching you every
little every little statement that you
make you know you walk down and you look
at someone's plan or you come down and
you look at a new task let's come down
and you go oh this is this is a bunch of
crap guess what everyone for now now
thinks they 100 percent percent think
it's a bunch of crap if you come down
and say hey look this is gonna be
challenging I think we can knock this
out of the park and then people go oh
yeah we're gonna knock this out of the
park so the way you act on a macro level
the way you act on a micro level as a
leader is gonna create the culture that
you're gonna live with Mike approves all
right let's uh let's wrap up I want to
hear about the muster in San Francisco
we have a lot of bay area listeners you
guys are doing another event what's the
deal yeah so we started doing the
musters a few years ago and basically
what happened was we as our as demand
increased for a tional enfant services
the price point went up and it continued
to go up through the years - till until
it got to a point where people that or
in small to mid-sized businesses really
couldn't afford to bring us in because
it just cost too much money and we
couldn't afford to do it because we had
too much stuff on our plate and to
satisfy so there was a lot of demands
for hey can you just do you know how can
we get you how can we do this how can we
make this work and so what we ended up
doing kind of I wouldn't say as a whim
but we definitely made an aggressive
decision I think it was in July when it
was okay you know what let's have an
event that people can come to and we'll
do it in San Diego and that's what we
did we called it the muster it was a two
day it's a two day leadership event we
did and and you know I said the lady
said and Jamie Cochran who's our who's
our ops director who's a incredible
asset and incredible person but she was
she had done some event management
before and it was hey I don't know and
he definitely concerned and I said you
know what let's go for it let's go for
it
here's a worst-case scenario worst-case
scenario 33 people show up we lose some
money we make a great event for them we
learn from it and maybe we adjust it and
we can get better in the future but
worst-case scenario we lose a little bit
of money no factor and we'll move
forward we so we said okay we'll go for
it we booked the place and we put it out
there and we sold about and so we had
the first muster was 350 people in San
Diego and then from there we went to New
York we went to Austin we came back to
San Diego we went to Washington DC we
sold out every event and they're awesome
they're intense leadership pragmatic
leadership information on how to become
a better leader we're doing this one
October 17th and 18th in San Francisco
California and obviously we got clients
up there that it makes it easy for them
it also is makes it easy for people that
might not be able to afford the Echelon
front full package services which the
primary the primary line of operation
for a tional in front is what do we do
long long range leadership alignment
programs with companies so we go in for
three months six months a year in some
cases and we get entire leadership teams
aligned and working together well and
overcoming their problems and their
issues which by the way every single
problem that companies face every single
problem that companies face is a
leadership problem and if you can come
up with an example if someone wants to
text me or or hit me up on Twitter with
an example that's not a leadership
problem like oh we're we have a problem
on our manufacturing line guess what the
leader is not set up that that
manufacturing line correctly guess what
we're not going to meet our numbers
guess what there's a leader that has as
in isn't driving his team in the correct
manner we aren't hiring the right people
well guess what we aren't leading
correctly to get the right people in the
door so every problem that a company has
does the leadership arm and that's a
hard statement for people to stomach
because what that means when you're in a
leadership position is wait chuckles
saying this is my fault
and I am saying it's your fault but the
good thing is it also puts it in your
hands to control it puts it in your
hands to change and lead correctly from
the top from the middle from the front
and make things happen and that's
when you that that the ELISA Seidel book
extreme ownership when you recognize
that hey when you stop saying hey you
know what it's the market and it's these
other people it's the competitors did
this and we didn't expect that the
minute you stop blaming everyone else
and everything else and you say okay
this is mine I'm gonna fix it here we go
the moment that you say that is the
moment you start to win no Craig I got
to tell you so my first muster was in
May in in DC and so I have no experience
with events like this you know with
chocolaty how this uh this sort of rolls
out and at the conclusion of it you know
I came home and you know once my fiancee
and I'm like dude these guys are
changing lives and just like you would
see the eyes open during the two days
and actually funny enough I live in
Austin saw a guy that worked out of my
gym no one's a supplement company in
Austin okay you're from Austin we start
talking I'm like well dude have a great
time in the muster and lo and behold I
run into him at the gym probably like
four weeks after the DC muster he's like
did that that has changed our entire
management philosophy and now we're in
the process of filtering it down all the
way to the frontline troops but it's
like we've rethought how we lead and so
how is that relevant to Silicon Valley
dude I couldn't think of a better
program for a start-up team to attend
and you will see the eyes open and
they'll be like okay we're doing we're
doing some things well we're doing some
things really well but we're doing a lot
of things the wrong way
and you know you talked about this
earlier question from Alex you know it
will increase your effectiveness it will
increase your thorough so yeah I'm Todd
yeah I'm a believer
100% Wow is it weird having all these
fanboys now you know I don't think I
really have like fanboys or whatever I
think what's cool about even you know
even going to the muster like we are
there yeah and and and you've you know
you hear me talk about the muster
there's no backstage there's no green
room where we're out there we we
literally sit with the audience and talk
with the audience the whole entire time
and so it turns into it so it's not
really
audience it's just a big group and do we
present we absolutely present do we get
feedback yes do we do cook QA
so I don't really think I'm I'm I don't
really think that we have fanboys I
think we have people that that are on
the same train with us and we're all
going in the same direction and is it
cool to be with a group of people that
want to go and get after it
yeah you know what it's awesome it's
awesome I'm stoked that this whole thing
has turned out this way and it's awesome
to meet people all over the world I mean
people come from all over the world to
come to the muster and it's awesome to
meet people from foreign countries from
America from every corner of this
country that are in the game they want
to crush it and they show up and they
teach us and we teach them and we all
move forward together it's awesome where
can I find out more the muster is
extreme ownership calm that's where you
register there's only one more we're
doing in this year and yeah that's it
extreme ownership calm national on fraud
is national on front calm Jaakko podcast
is chocol podcast calm that's it
that's it Mikey on Twitter I'm on
Twitter at mga sueli
reach out write I love the conversations
that go on in Twitter especially this
guy in Marc Andreessen from the early
man I love the the Jocko picture with
the hair that I stop floating around
like oh dude that was awesome yeah
that's from that's from the from the
from the 90s yeah forget nineties okay
I'm not long hair that was that was the
cool seal back dad that was when I was
younger and thought hey man this is
gonna be this is this is how I should be
that's a look yeah yeah what can I say
yeah I wasn't that bad all right thanks
guys thank you so much thanks Robert a
quick thanks
you